Buonasera, loro sono felici e soddisfatti, hanno raggiunto il risultato, io sono l'unico
che deve ancora lavorare questa sera. Allora, la terza delle nostre donne, Giovanna d'Arco,
su tre la seconda santa, anche se non l'hanno fatta santa subito come Caterina da Siena,
l'hanno fatta santa molto dopo, comunque due sante su tre, due mistiche su tre, due donne
completamente fuori del comune con una vita pazzesca e morte giovanissime su tre. Non
è che l'ho fatto apposta. Il problema è che Giovanna d'Arco, tanto per cambiare, come
Caterina da Siena era la donna più conosciuta e più documentata del Trecento, Giovanna d'Arco
è certamente la donna più conosciuta e più documentata della sua epoca, del Quattrocento.
tenete conto che è morta a 19 anni. Come mai sappiamo così tante cose su Giovanna d'Arco
per cui io stasera posso parlarvene per un'ora? Beh, qualche cosa di scritto da lei ce l'abbiamo
ma pochissimo, sapeva forse un po' leggere, ha dettato qualche lettera, ma sono manifesti
politici in realtà, lettere pubbliche di intervento. Non è questo il punto. Se noi
abbiamo più informazioni su Giovanna che su qualunque altra donna della sua epoca è
per il fatto che le hanno fatto due processi. Uno da viva, al preciso scopo di ammazzarla
legalmente e poi uno vent'anni dopo voluto dal re di Francia per dimostrare che il primo
processo era tutto sbagliato e che lei non era un'eretica e una criminale, ma al contrario
aveva ragione e Dio era con lei. Questi due processi contengono una quantità di informazioni,
voi direte, un processo, certo, informazioni stravolte, interrogatorie, risposte, però
comunque questi due processi contengono una quantità di informazioni su questa ragazza,
diciamo pure su questa ragazzina, stupefacente. Il processo che le hanno fatto gli inglesi dopo
averla catturata, ripeto, al preciso scopo di metterla a morte a qualunque costo, a costo
di, come dire, forzare la procedura, commettere delle illegalità. E beh, sì, era un processo
politico dall'esito scontato, ma le forme bisognava rispettarle. Era un processo su cui,
come dire, tutto il mondo stava a guardare questo processo. Quindi certe forme bisognava
rispettarle. È un processo, il primo processo, il processo di condanna di Giovanna, è un processo
che è durato quasi cinque mesi. Il collegio giudicante è arrivato a coinvolgere 131 fra
prelati, dottori, teologi, professori universitari. Ogni parola pronunciata da Giovanna è stata
trascritta e lei spesso chiedeva di rivedere, di farsi rileggere la trascrizione e più di
una volta è intervenuta a correggere la trascrizione, la verbalizzazione di quello che lei aveva
detto. E di questo processo sono state fatte parecchie coppie, per cui noi abbiamo ampiamente
gli atti enormi. Poi, vent'anni dopo, il re di Francia, che intanto ha vinto, il re di
Francia per cui Giovanna si era battuta, il re di Francia vent'anni dopo fa fare un altro
processo, per annullare il primo. Infatti il termine corretto è il processo di nullificazione.
E per rifare il processo postumo di Giovanna vanno a cercare tutti quelli che l'hanno conosciuta.
Sono passati più di vent'anni, ma ce n'è ancora tanti che l'hanno conosciuta e tutti testimoniano.
Ed è un testo strabiliante. Sono andati al villaggio a trovare le amiche di infanzia. C'è
l'amica di infanzia che all'epoca era una ragazzina e che adesso è una donna matura e
che si ricorda che quando Giovanna è partita dal paesino per andare a compiere il suo destino,
lei, l'amica, è scoppiata a piangere perché Giovanna, che era la sua amichetta del cuore,
se n'era andata senza salutarla. E c'è la testimonianza del nobile cavaliere il quale
ha combattuto insieme a Giovanna e si ricorda che quando la aiutava a vestire l'armatura
un'occhiatina a quei seni di ragazzina la dava ed erano belli, dice. Non è neanche un cavaliere
qualunque, è il duca di Alanson che lo dice. Sì, sì, quando le allacciavo la corazza un'occhiatina
la davo ed erano belli quei seni. E quando lei si curava le ferite, le gambe le vedevamo
tutti ed erano belle gambe. Ecco, per dirvi cosa si può trovare in questi verbali di questi
processi. Dunque di Giovanna sappiamo tante cose, perfino grossomodo quando è nata, grossomodo,
non è ovvio per la gente del Medioevo che non sapeva granché in che anno viveva e non stava
tanto a contare gli anni. Giovanna quando la processano nel 1431 dice di avere circa
19 anni. Si chiama, e noi la stiamo chiamando, Giovanna d'Arco, Jeanne d'Arc. In realtà è
una stortura, è una stortura moderna, siamo noi che la chiamiamo così. All'epoca nessuno
la chiama così. Lei stessa, non si chiama mai così, lei è Jeanne, Jeanne La Pucelle.
Dico apposta la Pucelle perché tradotto in italiano dovrebbe essere la pulzella, ma
io non so se voi siete d'accordo con me, in italiano pulzella è una parola ridicola,
è una parola che sembra una parodia di quei film finto medievali. Ecco, invece la Pucelle
nel francese della sua epoca non è una parola ridicola, vuol dire la vergine, certo, ma la
vergine in quanto è una ragazzina, è una ragazzina che non è ancora in età di sposarsi.
E dunque lei è Jeanne, Jeanne La Pucelle. D'Arco era il cognome del padre, certo, il
padre si chiamava Jacques D'Arc. La mamma si chiamava Isabelle Romè e al processo Giovanna,
non so neanche perché parla di questo a un certo punto, viene fuori anche questo, Giovanna
dice al mio paese le ragazze prendono il nome della mamma, il cognome della mamma. Sono
quelle cose che saltano fuori, uno meno se le aspetta, no? Una società patriarcale,
ovviamente, non è che al suo villaggio in Lorena fosse diverso. Eppure lì l'abitudine
è che i maschi prendono il cognome del padre, le femmine il cognome della mamma, quindi lei
semmai sarebbe stata Jeanne Romè, ma appena se ne va dal villaggio chi è che sa chi sono
i D'Arc, i Romè, non importa niente a nessuno. È Jeanne, Giovanna e basta, la pulzella.
È la figlia di un contadino e tutti sappiamo che parte del fascino di Giovanna è il fatto
che è una ragazzina qualunque, che viene dal nulla. In realtà poi diciamo che nell'immaginario
popolare questa cosa è stata anche esasperata, la pastorella, non è mai stata pastorella
neanche per idea. Comunque è la ragazzina che viene dagli strati più bassi della popolazione.
Ecco, su questo bisogna stare un po' attenti. Certo, è figlia di contadini, sono contadini,
ma i contadini non sono mica tutti uguali, ci sono anche i contadini ricchi. Al suo paese,
suo padre è un contadino ricco, è uno che conta. Giovanna, per esempio, ha un cugino
che è monaco. Essere monaco non vuol dire niente, essere monaco è qualcosa. Hai diritto
essere chiamato messere se sei monaco. Sei uno che conta. Giovanna ha un cugino monaco
e quando sarà col re al comando degli eserciti e dovrà scegliersi un confessore, farà venire
il cugino monaco. Ha un parente parroco. Ha diversi fratelli, i quali non la lasciano
sola. Attenzione, Giovanna, che parte per la sua missione pazzesca, io parlo come se lo sapeste
tutti, lo sapete tutti in realtà, lo riracconteremo, ma Giovanna parte per andare dal re e aiutarlo
a salvare la Francia contro gli inglesi nel momento più buio della guerra dei cent'anni.
Quando lei parte, dopo un po' arrivano anche i fratelli, perché la ragazza non la lasciamo
mica sola. Arrivano i fratelli e combattono al suo fianco. Uno dei fratelli, Pierre, sarà
catturato con lei. Poi Giovanna la tengono perché vogliono ammazzarla a tutti i costi.
Il fratello lo lasciano dietro pagamento di riscatto, come si usa fra i cavalieri all'epoca,
perché la guerra si fa per guadagnare e se fai un prigioniero poi lo rilasci facendogli
pagare un riscatto. Pierre sarà non solo riscattato, ma sarà fatto cavaliere dal re di Francia,
diventerà un nobile signore. I parenti di Giovanna fondano una famiglia nobile.
certo, contadini di un villaggio sperduto, ma anche qui attenzione, perché noi rischiamo
di avere un errore di prospettiva, che i contadini medievali fossero della gente bestiale che non
sapeva in che mondo viveva. Non è così. Al paese, al villaggio si fa politica. Il papà
di Giovanna è spesso sindaco del villaggio e quando Giovanna è all'apice del successo
ed è col re, il papà va a trovarla e torna a casa con l'esenzione dalle tasse per tutto
il villaggio. Perché al villaggio si fa politica e si fa anche la grande politica. Siamo nel
pieno della guerra dei cent'anni, sì. Siamo, l'ho detto prima, nel momento più buio per
i francesi. Sto prendendo posizioni inevitabilmente, mi sto schierando con Giovanna. Per i francesi
è il momento più buio della guerra dei cent'anni. Hanno perso la grande battaglia di
Asancourt. Il re inglese Enrico V è entrato a Parigi e si è fatto incoronare re di Francia.
E una parte dei francesi stanno con lui. La Francia è spaccata. I borgognoni stanno
col re inglese. Al re legittimo di Francia, che non è ancora re, è solo il Delfino, il
principe ereditario, rimane solo il sud della Francia. Il nord sta con gli inglesi, Parigi
sta con gli inglesi, la Sorbona sta con gli inglesi e il resto della Francia si spacca.
Il paesino di Giovanna è in terra fedele al Delfino. Ma nel paesino accanto sono borgognoni,
stanno con gli inglesi. E al processo Giovanna ricorda che al suo paesino i ragazzi fanno
a botte con quelli del paese vicino. Perché noi stiamo col Delfino, con Carlo, e quegli altri
stanno con l'inglese, con Enrico. Giovanna a un certo punto ha domanda al processo, dice
sino al villaggio noi stavamo tutti col Delfino, tranne uno. C'era uno al mio paese che stava
con i borgognoni e con gli inglesi. E dice Giovanna, mi sarebbe piaciuto vedergli tagliare
la testa. Poi si ricorda che è al processo che stanno scrivendo tutto e dice, cioè, se
fosse piaciuto a Dio. Perché Giovanna, come vedremo, al processo sa essere molto attenta
a quello che dice e a quello che verbalizzano.
Dunque non è che non sa niente, non è che perché uno è figlio di contadini non sa cosa
succede al mondo, lo sanno e come. Sanno che la Francia è dilaniata dalla guerra civile
e ognuno si schiera e prende parte. Giovanna da bambina. Avete sentito raccontare di Caterina
da Siena, chi di voi c'era l'altro ieri? Ci sono due opzioni. È una bambina come tutti
gli altri o è una bambina un po' speciale che già si capisce che c'è qualcosa di strano
in lei. Qui abbiamo il secondo processo, quello in cui interrogano tanti anni dopo
la gente che l'ha conosciuta, la gente del Paese. E lì tutti dicono, per carità, la
memoria si modifica a quel tempo, chi lo sa, se quelle cose che dicono sono vere o se se
le sono immaginate loro nel frattempo. Comunque tutti dicono, no, Giovanna si vedeva che era
diversa dagli altri. Andava sempre a messa. Ogni messa, mica solo la domenica, ogni messa
da morto che c'era al Paese, lei mollava il lavoro perché stava a casa a filare, come
tutte le brave bambine, mollava il lavoro e andava a messa. Si confessava il più possibile.
Notate che la Chiesa all'epoca, che considerava la confessione un sacramento estremamente serio,
diceva ai cristiani, ci si confessa una volta all'anno, a Pasqua. È obbligatorio confessarsi
a Pasqua. E basta così, perché non è una cosa da prendere sotto gamba. Confessarsi
più spesso non era visto di buon occhio. Giovanna si confessava a tutti i momenti. E
analizzando i testimoni del suo Paese che raccontano questa cosa, viene fuori questa cosa abbastanza
interessante. Tutti quelli più anziani, quelli della generazione dei suoi genitori,
dicono che bambina meravigliosa fosse stata nostra figlia. Era così pia, era così buona,
così religiosa, avremmo voluto averla noi una figlia così. I suoi coetanei, non è che
possono parlare male di Giovanna, però sotto sotto i suoi coetanei dicono sì, però esagerava
un po' tutto sommato. Era sempre lì che voleva andare a messa invece di venire a giocare
con noi. Quando si andava a ballare lei non ci stava e qualcuno di questa ragazzina, tutto
sommato, al Paese, qualcuno degli amici, ne parlava anche male, la prendevano in giro.
La Santarellina. Quando la Santarellina ha 12 o 13 anni comincia a sentire le voci. Chi
di voi c'è stato l'altro ieri sera? Mi dirà, ma queste donne del Medioevo sentivano
tutte le voci. No, ho cercato di dirlo all'inizio, non è quello. Il problema è che quelle che
sentivano le voci noi le conosciamo, perché di loro si è parlato. Giovanna comincia a sentire
le voci. E la prima volta ebbe molta paura. E questa voce venne verso mezzogiorno, d'estate,
nel giardino di suo padre, dalle testimonianze di Giovanna al processo. Veniva da destra, dalla
parte della chiesa e insieme c'era una gran luce. Voi capite che è importante, se veniva
da sinistra si poteva anche dubitare, tutto sommato, di questa voce che venisse davvero
da lassù e non da sotto. Invece veniva da destra, veniva dalla parte della chiesa. Giovanna
ci pensa un attimo, ha paura, subito, ma poi si convince che queste voci vengono da
Dio. E queste voci le dicono all'inizio che deve fare la brava bambina, che deve andare
spesso in chiesa, e poi cominciano a dirle che c'è qualcosa di più, che lei ha una missione,
che deve andare in Francia. Il suo villaggio è proprio sul confine, è in Lorena al confine
col Ducato di Borgogna. La Francia è dietro, più indietro. Il territorio controllato dal
Delfino è ancora più lontano. Lei deve andare dal Delfino per salvare la Francia.
A 12 o 13 anni non se ne parla neanche, ma quando comincia a averne 15 o 16, Giovanna
ci prova. Perché le voci continuano a esserci. Al processo dirà a un certo punto che lei le
sente tutti i giorni le voci. E a un certo punto ci prova. In un paesino lì vicino c'è
una guarnigione francese, al comando di un capitano del Delfino. E lei scappa di casa,
va fin lì, va dal capitano e gli dice Dio mi ha mandato per salvare la Francia. Ancora
una volta, come nel caso di Caterina, noi potremmo dire, beh, questa gente del Medioevo era pronta
a credere a queste cose. Chissà come avrà reagito. Il capitano del Delfino reagisce esattamente
come farebbe oggi un capitano dei Carabinieri se gli arrivasse una ragazzina che dice sono
scappata di casa perché devo andare a salvare il paese. Il capitano dei Carabinieri telefona
alla famiglia dicendo venite a riprenderla e controllatela un po' di più. Il capitano del
Delfino chiama la famiglia e dice riportatela a casa, datele due ceffoni e non voglio più
sentirne parlare di queste scemenze. La riportano a casa. Giovanna continua a fremere. I familiari
si spaventano. Qui c'è un punto in cui non reagiscono esattamente come reagiremmo noi,
un punto in cui ci aiuta a capire come ragionava questa gente. La mamma a un certo punto racconta
Giovanna la seguente cosa. Le dice sì, la prima volta che sei scappata di casa e che
poi si capiva che eri pronta a scappare di nuovo e scappare dal punto di vista del papà
e dei fratelli per far cosa? Per andare dal capitano, dai soldati, per scappare con i
soldati. Sì che sanno loro che c'è la missione divina. Agli occhi del padre e dei fratelli
questa è l'ennesima ragazzina che vuol scappare di casa per andare con i soldati. Tenete conto
che la Francia vive nella guerra da anni, che l'abitudine alla guerra, al passaggio dei
soldati e anche l'emozione, l'eccitazione passano i soldati, chissà dove vanno poi.
Ecco, di ragazze che scappano con i soldati ce ne sono tante. E come finiscono? Finiscono
tutti a far la puttana. E per il padre e per i fratelli quella è la prospettiva. E la
mamma dice a Giovanna, guarda che allora io li ho sentiti tuo padre e i tuoi fratelli.
Loro non sapevano che io li stavo ascoltando dall'altra parte. Loro parlavano e dicevano
questa qui finirà che scappa con i soldati e finisce come finisce. E il nostro onore sarà
perduto. Disonora la famiglia. È meglio affogarla nello stagno. E il papà e i fratelli
per un momento si sono detti, guarda, la affoghiamo nello stagno e così non se ne parla più.
E il nostro onore sarà salvo.
Qui io apro una piccola parentesi. Mi sono chiesto a lungo se aprirla perché ci perdo
5 minuti. Mi gioco 5 dei miei minuti. Ma la apro lo stesso. Perché a me, in passato,
mi è capitato di trovarla nei documenti, una vicenda di questo tipo. Io una volta ho trovato
nell'archivio di Aosta un processo del 300 che parla precisamente di questo. C'è una famiglia
di contadini ricchi, agiati, padroni di bestiame. E hanno una ragazza in famiglia, una sorella,
che ruba. E ruba e non si riesce a impedire. Noi oggi diremmo malata, cleptomane. Ruba.
Ha rubato già diverse volte. La giustizia dell'epoca è sbrigativa. Il ladro la prima
volta, lo bastoni la seconda volta, gli taglia un'orecchia. Così la gente lo vede e sa che
è un pregiudicato. Alla ragazza le hanno già fatto, le hanno già tagliato un'orecchia
una volta. E lei continua a rubare. Ci capiamo? E non sto parlando di Giovanna d'Arco. Sto
parlando di questa storia che io ho trovato a un certo punto nell'archivio di Aosta e
che richiama molto da vicino quello che il papà e i fratelli di Giovanna a un certo
punto hanno pensato di fare. In questo documento valdostano si legge che i fratelli della ragazza
si dicono. Questa ci disonora. Ma andiamola fuori dal paese. La portiamo dall'altra parte
delle montagne. E che vada con Dio. Il padre e i fratelli lo decidono. I fratelli la portano
via. Salgono, si arrampicano su verso il Gran San Bernardo. Immaginate questa camminata
tutto il giorno. Quando arrivano su al Gran San Bernardo, o quasi, subito sotto, nel
Vallone di Vertosan, i fratelli si dicono. Questa qui, la sorella, arriverà di là e
ricomincerà a rubare. E chiederanno chi è. Si saprà che è nostra sorella. La rimanderanno
di qua. La faranno impiccare i signori del paese. E noi saremo disonorati. Affoghiamola
nel lago. C'è il laghetto sotto il Gran San Bernardo e loro prendono la sorella e la affogano
nel lago. E noi abbiamo il processo. I signori del paese che si sono trovati molto in difficoltà
in questo caso. E hanno chiesto consigli. Molti nobili della Val d'Aosta sono venuti
a dare il loro consiglio. E alla fine hanno deciso sì sì. Li hanno condannati a pagare
una grossa multa. E basta. Perché credevano di far bene. Questo per dire che queste cose
succedevano. E Giovanna ci è andata vicina. E Giovanna però è sempre lì. Il papà e i
fratelli non si risolvono a questo passo estremo. Lei è sempre in casa. Che freme.
Lei stessa a un certo punto al processo di Ra è venuto un momento che non ce la facevo
più a sopportare. Mi sembrava che il tempo non passasse mai. Dice Giovanna. Sono riportate
nel processo alla terza persona le sue dichiarazioni. Il tempo le sembrava interminabile come a una
donna incinta. E cito questo di nuovo perché Giovanna come Caterina da Siena di cui abbiamo
parlato è una che non è mai stata incinta. Che è morta vergine. E però è chiaro che
anche per lei la cultura che lei ha assorbito da bambina è questa. La cultura delle donne
è innanzitutto questo. La gravidanza, essere incinte, il parto. Queste sono le cose che
tutte loro conoscono. Anche chi non le ha conosciute direttamente come Giovanna le viene naturale
usare queste immagini. Ero lì che non ce la facevo più, che contavo i giorni come una
donna incinta. E finalmente scappa di nuovo di casa. E stavolta le va bene. Stavolta il capitano
del delfino le dice, il delfino, mi capite, l'aspirante re di Francia, il re d'Inghilterra
si è fatto incoronare re di Francia. C'è il legittimo re francese che però non è stato
ancora incoronato. Perciò lo chiamano ancora il delfino, l'erede. Il capitano del delfino
stavolta, quando si vede arrivare questa ragazzina che a quel punto ha 17 anni, decide
di darle fiducia e di mandarla dal delfino. E qui ci vuole una piccola spiegazione di contesto.
Giovanna non è la prima che arriva dicendo che lei ha sentito le voci e che Dio vuol salvare
il regno di Francia. Perché se fosse stata la prima, se fosse stato un fenomeno unico,
chi lo sa come avrebbero reagito. Invece non è così. In questa società capita con una
certa frequenza che ci sia qualcuno che si sente portatore di un messaggio divino. In questa
Francia, sprofondata nella guerra civile e nell'occupazione straniera, capita con una
certa frequenza. Una certa frequenza vuol dire una volta all'anno, una volta ogni due o tre
anni, una volta ogni cinque anni. Però è già successo. Arrivano le persone che hanno le
visioni. Uomini e soprattutto donne. Donne e soprattutto ragazzine. Povere di solito,
analfabete, contadine. Arrivano e dicono Dio mi ha parlato. Dio mi manda dal re, dal
delfino per salvare la Francia. E bene o male tutti hanno l'idea che potrebbero anche
essere vere queste cose. Qualche anno prima dell'avventura di Giovanna, l'Università di
Parigi, in un momento particolarmente cupo per il Regno, ha pubblicato addirittura un appello
pubblico, una circolare. L'Università di Parigi invitava, cito, le persone pie che conducono
vita buona e hanno il dono della profezia, le invitava a manifestarsi per la salvezza del
Regno. Dunque ci si aspetta che possa accadere una cosa del genere. La seconda volta che Giovanna
va alla fortezza di Vaucouleur, al capitano del delfino, il capitano del delfino stavolta
ha sentito parlare di lei, perché sono anni che lei sta a casa a smaniare. E nella zona
ormai lo sanno tutti, che lei ha le visioni e sente le voci. Ormai la conoscono. E stavolta
il capitano decide di rischiare, di mandarla dal delfino. Non è una decisione da poco.
Le compra un cavallo, le regala una spada. Giovanna ha una condizione precisa. Lei andrà,
ma siccome va non soltanto per annunciare una profezia, ce ne sono state altre che annunciavano
la profezia. Lei va dal delfino per dirgli, Dio mi ha detto di guidare i tuoi eserciti e
sconfiggere gli stranieri e cacciarli dalla Francia. E queste cose non si fanno se si è
vestite da donna. Quindi Giovanna parte dicendo, io ci vado vestita da uomo. E gli abitanti del
villaggio si tassano e le comprano un vestito da uomo. E lei si taglia i capelli a scodella,
che è la moda maschile dell'epoca, si taglia i capelli da uomo, si veste da uomo, sale sul
cavallo che le ha comprato il capitano e parte per raggiungere il delfino nella valle della
loira. Undici giorni di viaggio, con una scorta di uomini d'arme forniti dal capitano
del delfino, che si è preso a questo punto la responsabilità di mandarla avanti questa
qui. Arriva dal delfino. Un testimone dirà poi al processo che aveva i capelli corti e
un berretto di lana. Ed era vestita da uomo, ma un vestito molto semplice. Gliel'han comprato
i contadini del suo paese. Arriva dal delfino. Di nuovo, quanto è diverso quel mondo dal nostro
e quanto è uguale. È molto diverso. Il delfino la riceve. Lei dice che deve parlare da sola
con lui. È come se fosse il re, per i francesi legittimisti, per i francesi leali, il delfino.
Lei dice che deve parlargli da sola. E il delfino, il re, la riceve da solo. E lei gli spiega
che è stata mandata da Dio. Il delfino dice che lo so, l'ho già sentito, per annunciare.
No, no, no, non per annunciare, per farlo. Gli inglesi stanno assediando Orléans. È una
città cruciale, perché se gli inglesi prendono Orléans, avranno accesso, passano
la Loira, avranno accesso alla Francia del sud, potranno invadere i territori ancora sotto
il controllo francese. Questo assedio di Orléans è cruciale. Giovanna, che vive a 300 chilometri
di distanza, lo sa che c'è questo assedio, ne ha sentito parlare. E lei dice al delfino,
no, no, niente annuncio. Io sono stata mandata per comandare il tuo esercito e andare a cacciare
gli inglesi, togliere l'assedio di Orléans e poi portarti a Reims, che è la città dove
per tradizione i re di Francia vengono incoronati, e farti incoronare re di Francia. Un mondo,
vi dicevo, diverso dal nostro. Il delfino la riceve in privato e la ascolta. Un mondo molto
simile al nostro. Il delfino, per prima cosa, pensa, ecco un'altra matta scatenata. Come
faccio a liberarmi di lei? E soprattutto, se le do retta, che figura ci faccio? Questo
viene fuori molto chiaramente, che il delfino a un certo punto ne parla con i suoi consiglieri.
e se poi si rivela tutta una truffa? Tutto il mondo riderà di noi. Però non è detto
che non sia vero. Non è detto che non sia una vera profetessa. Come si fa a saperlo?
Si convoca una commissione. Si convoca una commissione di esperti, di teologi, di giuristi,
di consiglieri del re, di politici, i quali per un mese interrogano Giovanna e la esaminano.
An passant, siccome lei dice ho fatto voto di verginità e così via, si fa anche un esame
di verginità, anzi due già che ci sono, commissioni di dame di corte che la esaminano
per verificare che effettivamente è vergine, come lei dice. E i teologi la esaminano e la
analizzano e discutono con lei. Le chiedono di tutto. Uno dei teologi le chiede ma queste
voci che tu senti, ma in che lingua parlano? Purtroppo il teologo è uno del meridione,
parla con un fortissimo accento meridionale. Giovanna gli risponde parlano in francese
molto meglio di voi. Commissione verifica che è sincera, che è buona, che è pia, che è
umile, che è devota. La Commissione verifica una serie di altre cose abbastanza significative
per noi. Ne abbiamo già parlato tanto parlando di Caterina da Siena, quindi non mi fermo
troppo, però bisogna saperlo, che Giovanna da questo punto di vista cammina sulla stessa
strada di Caterina da Siena. Non mangia niente. La Commissione lo testifica e lo verbalizza.
mangia al massimo due volte al giorno e spesso solo un pezzo di pane. Era stupefacente
quanto mangiava poco. Testimonierà poi uno che l'ha conosciuta bene al processo. Seconda
cosa, non ha le mestruazioni. A 17 anni sarebbe già ora, lei sarà perché non mangia niente,
non le ha. E su questa cosa, di nuovo, i teologi sono colpiti, sono interessati, perché
è carica di valenze simboliche questa faccenda. Non ha mestruazioni come la Madonna, probabilmente.
Però i teologi dell'epoca su questo sono spaccati. Maria le aveva o non le aveva? Non
è un dogma. Si può discutere. Ed è una roba abbastanza interessante se uno pensa che
Maria sia stata davvero la madre di Dio e che Dio si sia incarnato e sia venuto in
mezzo agli uomini tramite lei. È una faccenda piuttosto interessante dal loro punto di vista
di allora. E i teologi si spaccano. I teologi francescani dicono no, Maria non le aveva le
mestruazioni. Era talmente perfetta e nata senza peccato, non è ancora un dogma l'immacolata
concezione all'epoca, che non le aveva. I teologi domenicani dicono sì, sì, le aveva
Maria, perché lei era donna pienamente, quindi le aveva. Anche qui sono andato fuori del seminato,
ma il fatto che Giovanna non le avesse, per gli uomini che la esaminavano, tutti maschi,
evocava tutto questo genere di questioni. Questo dobbiamo saperlo. Alla fine la Commissione
conclude che Giovanna è sincera e che forse è davvero Dio che la manda. Vale la pena di
rischiare. Nella discussione con questa Commissione, di cui ugualmente abbiamo i verbali, conosciamo
molto, vale la pena di sottolineare un aspetto di Giovanna. Giovanna, l'abbiamo detto, è,
o forse no, lo dico adesso, è analfabeta. Poi impara un po' a firmare, ma sostanzialmente
è analfabeta e ha una grande sicurezza che le è data dalle sue visioni, dalle voci che
le parlano e che le permette di sentirsi superiore a tutti questi intellettuali maschi
che con i loro tavoli carichi di libri vanno a cercare nei libri le domande e le risposte.
Giovanna, a verbale, a un certo punto, quando qualcuno le dice, ma non si è mai sentito che
Dio mandi una ragazza per comandare gli eserciti e vincere le guerre, Giovanna risponde
il Signore ha un libro che nessun chierico ha mai letto, per quanto sia istruito. E un'altra
volta, quando la Commissione continua a dirle che insomma questa cosa è poco credibile, Giovanna
dice, nei libri del Signore ci sono più cose che nei vostri. E i libri del Signore, appunto,
è lei che li conosce, perché il Signore a lei parla, è lei che incarna questa missione.
Dunque, la conclusione è proviamoci. Immediatamente si mette in movimento una complessa macchina politica
e militare per vedere se Giovanna effettivamente è la carta vincente. Parte la propaganda, si
vanno a riscoprire le profezie, come per incanto saltano fuori le profezie. Una ragazzina proveniente
dalla Lorena salverà il Regno di Francia. In realtà circolava già, la stessa Giovanna
l'ha letta e probabilmente quello l'ha anche motivata. Quindi escono gli opuscoli, i trattati,
gli instant book, le profezie, la salvatrice del Regno, il Regno salvato da una ragazza,
da una Pussell. E al tempo stesso noi dobbiamo immaginare, anche se nessuno ce lo dice, che
le abbiano insegnato a portare l'armatura, che non è uno scherzo, a andare a cavallo con
l'armatura, a combattere, perché tutte queste cose Giovanna alla fine le saprà fare, lo
dicono tutti. Ma non sono cose che si improvvisano e anzi appare incredibile che in poche settimane
gliel'abbiano insegnato, ma devono per forza averglielo insegnato. E la preparano, è una
ragazzina di 17 anni, e voi mi capite, la preparano a comandare l'esercito in guerra. Le
danno uno scudiero, un paggio, come a un nobile. Il re le fa fabbricare un'armatura, noi abbiamo
i conti dell'armaiolo, carissima, un'armatura da principe. Le regalano dei cavalli, perché
un comandante in guerra non è mica un cavallo solo, ne ha tanti. Le testimonianze sono concordi.
Giovanna cavalca sul suo grande cavallo nero da battaglia, in armatura, a testa scoperta,
con un'ascia in mano, e portava l'armatura con tanta scioltezza, come se non avesse fatto
altro in tutta la vita. Come abbiano fatto non lo sa nessuno. Il re le assegna uno stemma,
e la figlia del sindaco di Domremy, il quale intanto è arrivato per farsi fare l'esenzione
fiscale per tutto il villaggio, già che c'era, ma comunque è una contadina, non importa,
nobilitata. Il re la nobilità le assegna uno stemma, due gigli d'oro in campo azzurro,
e sono i gigli di Francia, è lo stemma del re, e in mezzo ai gigli d'oro una spada
levata che regge una corona. Non potrebbe essere più chiaro di così. La corona di Francia
in quel momento si regge sulla spada di Giovanna. Al processo i giudici al servizio degli inglesi
cercheranno di incastrarla su questo stemma. Che vanità portare uno stemma del genere,
uno stemma degno di un re. Giovanna dirà, io non l'ho mai portato. I suoi fratelli però
sì, i fratelli lo portano e come. E a questo punto Giovanna entra in azione. Al comando dell'esercito
marcia su Orléans e scrive la prima delle sue cinque o sei lettere pubbliche, la lettera
agli inglesi. 22 marzo 1429. È una lettera di una sicurezza di sé terrificante. Sono trenta
righe. Il pronome io figura sei volte. Il sostantivo la pulzella come soggetto, la pulzella
farà questo, farà quell'altro. Figura sette volte. Ve ne leggo due squarci. Re d'Inghilterra.
Il re d'Inghilterra in quel momento è un bambino, Enrico VII. Sesto, scusate. Quindi c'è
un reggente, il duca di Bedford. Re d'Inghilterra. E voi, duca di Bedford, che vi dite reggente
del regno di Francia, restituite alla pulzella che è mandata qui da Dio, il re del cielo, le
chiavi di tutte le città che avete preso e violentato in Francia. E voi, arcieri, mercenari,
nobili e altri, che assediate la città di Orlean, andatevene nel vostro paese per ordine
di Dio. E se non lo fate, aspettatevi notizie della pulzella, che fra poco verrà a vedervi
con vostro grande danno. Re d'Inghilterra, se non fate così, io sono capo di guerra. E
in qualunque luogo raggiungerò i vostri uomini in Francia, li farò andare via, che vogliano
o che non vogliano. E se non vogliono obbedire, li farò ammazzare tutti. Io sono qui mandata
da Dio, il re del cielo, il mio corpo al posto del suo, per buttarvi fuori da tutta
la Francia. Gli inglesi che assediano Orlean ricevono questa lettera e rispondono che la
bruceranno perché è solo una puttana e che se ne torni a guardare le vacche. Giovanna
attacca. Al processo si discuterà. Giovanna dice, io la spada mai usata, mai versato sangue.
Alcuni testimoni contraddicono. La spada certamente la impugnava. Se abbia colpito qualcuno o no,
non è detto. Certamente la spada la impugnava e certamente attaccava alla testa delle truppe.
Non sono le grandi battaglie in campo aperto. C'è l'assedio di Orlean, le fortificazioni,
le trincee. Si tratta di scalare dei baluardi, dei bastioni, mentre piovono i quadrelli delle
balestre, piovono le pietre, l'olio bollente, di arrampicarsi sulle scale. Tutti l'hanno
vista, Giovanna, con la spada o con lo stendardo in pugno che si arrampica sulle scale e conduce
l'assalto. Complessivamente in pochi mesi è ferita quattro volte. La prima volta è ferita
perché calpesta un tribolo. Cos'è un tribolo? Fuori dalle trincee si buttano triangoli di
ferro con le punte da tutte le parti, in modo che chi passa li pesta. La prima volta
lei pesta un tribolo, si fa male al piede. La seconda volta la ferisce un quadrello di
balestra alla spalla. Un'altra volta la ferisce una pietra che le viene addosso. La quarta
volta non so più dove, alla coscia, credo. Insomma, combatte. Combatte e vince e stravince.
Va ad Orlean, uno dopo l'altro prende tutti i bastioni e le trincee degli inglesi che assediavano
Orlean. Orlean è libera. Giovanna entra in città col delfino, tra festeggiamenti memorabili.
Gli inglesi preparano un esercito per venire alla riscossa. Giovanna va ad affrontarlo.
Li sconfigge. È la battaglia di Patè del 18 giugno del 29. Li sbaraglia in campo aperto.
A questo punto gli inglesi sono in piena rotta. La scena è pronta perché il delfino possa fare
quello che non ha avuto il coraggio di fare per anni. Spingersi fino a Reims, la città
sacra delle incoronazioni, e farsi incoronare re di Francia. Il 16 luglio Giovanna entra a
Reims con lo stendardo in pugno accanto al delfino e il delfino nella cattedrale gotica
di Reims viene incoronato Carlo VII, re di Francia. Tre mesi, maggio, giugno, luglio. In tre mesi
Giovanna ha vinto la guerra dei cent'anni. Diciamo pure che sarà ancora lunga, ma ha
completamente cambiato l'andamento della guerra e ha trasformato il delfino che era il candidato
perdente nel candidato vincente e nel vero re di Francia. Su Giovanna in questi mesi non
abbiamo tantissime testimonianze. Ce n'è qualcuna che ci dice che lei anche in questo contesto
non è che fraternizza troppo con i maschi. Lei ha delle donne con sé, cameriere, dame
di compagnia, sta con loro, dorme con loro, però sa anche stare con gli uomini d'arme
e con loro scherza, pacche sulle spalle. Sono venuti i suoi fratelli perché lei è una
ragazza onesta, ci sono i fratelli. Quindi non è che si può spettegolare su questa
ragazzina che sta con i soldati, c'è la famiglia che la controlla. Lei poi è abbastanza
ossessionata da queste cose. Ci sono testimonianze che ci dicono che c'era una cosa che lei non
reggeva, il fatto che al campo con i soldati è sempre pieno di prostitute e lei queste
prostitute che stavano con i soldati non le reggeva proprio e più di uno si ricorda
di averla vista, che correva dietro alle prostitute con la spada per cacciarle dall'accampamento
e intanto le folle arrivano, le folle festanti che vogliono vedere il miracolo, come diceva
Christine de Pisan per chi c'era ieri sera, l'onore del nostro sesso. Le folle sono lì
in ginocchio che vogliono baciarle la mano, al processo i giudici glielo diranno ti sei
fatta baciare la mano, vanno a gloria, che vogliono toccarle l'abito e farsi battezzare
da lei i loro bambini che gli faccia da madrina, lei li battezza, se sono bambine le fa chiamare
Giovanna, se sono maschili li fa chiamare Carlo come il re e poi, ahimè che poco tempo
che ci resta, ci sarebbero ancora tante cose da dire, e poi cosa succede? Succede che tutto
va a finire male molto rapidamente, che il delfino diventato re Carlo VII decide che ha
già ottenuto tutto quello che poteva sperare di ottenere, che più di così è impossibile
e che questa matta che continua a scalpitare per continuare la guerra comincia a essere un
fastidio, durante l'inverno 29-30 stanno fermi, non fanno niente, Giovanna scalpita,
provano a prendere Parigi, che è alleata degli inglesi, non ci riescono, è il primo
scacco di Giovanna, lì all'assalto delle mura di Parigi, Giovanna è ferita per la quarta
volta, poi pausa invernale, in primavera si ricomincia, il delfino non ci crede tanto,
Giovanna sì, vanno a scontrarsi con i borgognoni, i soliti maledetti borgognoni traditori
che sono alleati degli inglesi, a compiegno, fuori dalla città c'è una scaramuccia, Giovanna
si trova sola con qualcuno dei suoi cavalieri, la tagliano fuori, la catturano, i borgognoni
alleati degli inglesi, Giovanna è presa, gli altri che sono con lei, compreso suo fratello,
lo dicevo prima, pagano un riscatto e tornano a casa, come si usa allora secondo le regole della
guerra cavalleresca che ovviamente è fatta per guadagnare soldi e quindi i prigionieri
pagano e tornano a casa, Giovanna no, Giovanna è troppo preziosa, gli inglesi la vogliono,
non l'hanno presa gli inglesi, l'hanno presa i borgognoni, Giovanna rimane prigioniera da
maggio quando l'hanno presa fino all'autunno, prigioniera del conte di Lussemburgo che è un
vassallo del duca di Borgogna, prigioniera in un suo castello insieme con le donne della
famiglia, trattata benissimo, una volta cerca di scappare dalla finestra si rompe una gamba,
devono curarla, però va tutto bene in apparenza, ma gli inglesi sono lì che insistono perché la
vogliono e finalmente verso la fine dell'anno, 1430, gli inglesi si mettono d'accordo con i
borgognoni e si fanno consegnare Giovanna e decidono di processarla, non osano farla
andare a Parigi, troppo pericoloso, la fanno andare in Normandia che è la zona vicino all'Inghilterra
dove gli inglesi sono più forti, c'è il lungo viaggio di Giovanna prigioniera fino a Rouen,
capitale della Normandia, con le folle di gente che continuano a venire a vederla, specialmente
donne ci viene detto, che vogliono vedere, lo dice un testimone al processo, questa meraviglia
del loro sesso, sono le stesse parole di Cristina che abbiamo citato ieri. Fine del
30 Giovanna arriva a Rouen, 3 gennaio 1431 il re d'Inghilterra pubblica un manifesto in
cui dichiara, Enrico per grazia di Dio re di Francia e d'Inghilterra eccetera eccetera,
è notorio che da un po' di tempo una donna che si fa chiamare Giovanna la pulzella, lasciando
l'abito di sesso femminile, che è cosa contro la legge divina, abominevole a Dio, svergognata
e proibita da ogni legge, vestita abbigliata e armata in abito d'uomo, ha esercitato delitti
crudeli di omicidio e ha dato a intendere alla gente semplice per sedurla e ingannarla
che lei era mandata da Dio e che aveva conoscenza dei suoi divini segreti. Perciò continua il
re d'Inghilterra e noi abbiamo intenzione di processarla per questi suoi crimini, per
aver fatto credere che lei è mandata da Dio, per aver fatto credere che Dio parla con la
sua voce e per essersi vestita da uomo che è la dimostrazione che lei disprezza ogni
legge naturale, divina, della Chiesa e così via. Perciò la consegneremo, dice, alla Chiesa
perché sia processata. Poi c'è questa piccola frase finale. Se per caso dovesse succedere
che in questo processo non venga condannata, è nostra intenzione di riaverla e riprenderla,
perché comunque non la lasceranno andare. Dopodiché la consegnano alla Chiesa però,
perché l'idea è che è la Chiesa che deve, secondo le regole, processare Giovanna. Quale
Chiesa? Quella fedele agli inglesi, naturalmente. E qui comincia la storia straordinaria del processo
che io dovrò abbreviare, ma un pochettino ve lo devo raccontare perché il processo di
Giovanna è un momento straordinario. Gli inglesi trovano l'uomo giusto per processare
Giovanna. Cochon, vescovo di Beauvais. Beauvais è la diocesi dove Giovanna è stata catturata,
perché qui si fanno le cose corrette e legali. Un vescovo qualunque non può mica giudicarla,
deve essere o il vescovo dove lei abita, e li va a sapere, oppure il vescovo dove ha commesso
il reato. È stata catturata in armi da uomo in diocesi di Beauvais, perciò sarà il vescovo
di Beauvais a giudicarla. Caso vuole che Cochon, vescovo di Beauvais, sia un amicissimo degli inglesi.
Un politicante famoso, strettamente legato al regime degli occupanti. Quindi Cochon ha
il preciso incarico di farla finita con Giovanna, ma con un processo legale, perché tutto il
mondo sta a vedere cosa succede. Di cosa la dobbiamo processare? Va a sapere, non è mica
così chiaro, sei vestita da uomo, sì vabbè. Bisogna trovare l'argomento per processarla.
Il processo inizia con una serie di interrogatori di testimoni e raccolta di materiali con cui
il vescovo di Beauvais e una squadra di teologi raccolgono informazioni su Giovanna. Finalmente,
dopo un mese, il 19 febbraio, decidono che sul loro tavolo ci sono sufficienti informazioni.
Ha davvero preteso di essere una profetessa mandata da Dio, eccetera, eccetera, eccetera.
Ce n'è abbastanza perché l'inquisizione se ne interessi. Inquisizione finora non è entrata
niente in questo, è la chiesa, il vescovo. Mi rendo conto che per chi non è del mestiere
sembrano sottigliezze. Ma un conto è il vescovo che governa la sua chiesa locale e un conto
è il tribunale dell'inquisizione. Ma la vogliono processare per eresia perché se ti
vesti da uomo e sei una donna vuol dire che non accetti l'insegnamento della chiesa che
dice alle donne di vestirsi da donne. E quindi sei un'eretica, oltre che per tutte le altre
cose. Dunque, si farà un processo per eresia. Per fare un processo per eresia ci vuole un
inquisitore. Cosson si rivolge all'inquisitore di Francia, che è filo inglese, per invitarlo
a prendere parte al processo. L'inquisitore di Francia fa sapere che gli dispiace molto,
ma lui ha un altro processo molto importante, non ha assolutamente tempo, non può partecipare
a questo processo. Cosson si rivolge al vice inquisitore di Francia, che è titolare per
la diocesi di Rouen, dove si terrà il processo. Il vice inquisitore titolare per Rouen fa sapere
che sì, lui è titolare per Rouen, ma il reato è avvenuto nella diocesi di Beauvais, quindi
in realtà non sarebbe mica lui quello che è veramente responsabile per questa cosa.
Quindi lui, senza autorizzazione superiore, in questo processo non vuole averci niente a
che fare. Cosson freme, finalmente si rivolge all'inquisitore in capo, ottiene l'autorizzazione
perché il suo vice faccia parte del tribunale, finalmente, senza che nessuno ne abbia voglia,
l'inquisizione accetta, malvolentieri, di gestire questo processo, che tutti sanno benissimo
che è un processo politico, tutti sanno benissimo che gli inglesi hanno già deciso come deve
andare a finire, e nessuno ha tanta voglia di sporcarsi le mani con questo processo.
E' talmente complicata la cosa che Cosson e il vice inquisitore hanno bisogno di un sacco
di consigli. Come vi dicevo all'inizio, alla fine dei quei cinque mesi avranno convocato
131 fra professori universitari, teologi, canonici, eccetera, per consigliarli. Molti di questi
fanno poi sapere, in seguito al processo successivo di nullificazione, che loro non ci volevano
mica andare, e che l'hanno capito benissimo che questo processo era una cosa storta, e
che farlo lì a Rouen con i soldati inglesi fuori che pattugliavano non andava bene, e tuttavia
hanno dovuto accettare. Qualcuno non accetta, qualcuno se ne va, gli corrono dietro, lo minacciano,
ci sono tutta una serie di scene, di gente che rifiuta di partecipare a questo processo
e con la forza li costringono a sedere in tribunale. È un processo in cui Giovanna
non ha un avvocato, e questo purtroppo, tocca dirlo, è legale perché nei processi di inquisizione
l'imputato non ha diritto a un avvocato. Del resto è tardissimo, piccola digressione
lo stesso, mi scuserete, di un attimo. È anche normale perché il processo di inquisizione
mira una cosa sola, a far dire all'imputato, avete ragione, mi ero sbagliato, mi pento.
Se l'imputato dice, avete ragione, mi pento, l'inquisizione non lo può più bruciare.
E lo scopo è quello, quando bruci qualcuno è perché ne hai fallito. Lo scopo è di convincerlo
a pentirsi e a riconoscere che la Chiesa ha sempre ragione. Quindi si capisce anche che
non ci sia bisogno di avvocato. Sei tu che devi dire sì, hai ragione, mi pento, ho cambiato
idea. Dunque, Giovanna non ha un avvocato, ma a parte questo, le cose si fanno con estrema
legalità, si verbalizza tutto. La convocano e cominciano le sedute pubbliche in cui interrogano
Giovanna. A dire il vero c'è un errore di procedura. Magari vi annoio, ma per noi storici
sono quelle cose cruciali, andare a vedere, vogliono fare le cose così per bene. In realtà
c'è un errore di procedura colossale, perché all'inizio di un processo per inquisizione
bisogna notificare all'accusato i capi d'accusa. Lì non li hanno ancora i capi d'accusa.
Vogliono prima interrogarla e vedere se riescono a incastrarla, a farle dire qualche cosa di grosso
e su quello accusarla. È illegale, lo fanno lo stesso. Quando Giovanna, nella prima seduta,
nella cappella del castello di Rouen si presenta ai suoi giudici, per prima cosa le dicono
devi giurare sul Vangelo che dirai la verità. È illegale, perché senza capo d'accusa non
si può chiedere all'accusato di giurare che dirà la verità. Qui comincia, la faccio
breve, una storia che ha lasciato stupefatti tutti gli analisti di questo processo, perché
sembra quasi che Giovanna conosca il diritto canonico e che si difenda sulla base delle
irregolarità che commettono i suoi giudici. Quando le chiedono di giurare sul Vangelo
che dirà la verità, è come se Giovanna sapesse che non hanno il diritto di chiederglielo.
E lei risponde, ma io non lo so mica cosa mi chiederete. Come faccio a giurarvi che dirò
la verità? Potreste chiedermi delle cose che non voglio dirvi. Potreste chiedermi delle
cose che mi ha rivelato Dio nelle visioni e mi ha proibito di rivelare. E io non posso
spergiurare a Dio per giurare a voi. Potreste chiedermi delle cose che il mio re mi ha detto
in segreto, ordinandomi di non rivelarle a nessuno. Io giuro, se proprio volete, che se
mi interrogate in questioni di fede sulle mie credenze dirò la verità. Su tutto il resto
mi riservo di mentire. E i giudici, dopo innumerevoli discussioni, accettano questo
giuramento, perché non si può fare diversamente. Non si può obbligarla a giurare.
E già che c'è, Cochon le chiede di giurare che non cercherà di scappare. Come pensate
che abbia risposto? Non giura. Risultato, durante tutto il processo Giovanna è in cella, dorme
incatenata e con cinque guardie nella cella che la controllano. Notate che è sempre vestita
da uomo, perché cercano di convincerla a vestirsi da donna e lei tiene duro e non si
veste da donna. Ci sono delle schermaglie straordinarie. A un certo punto le dicono
se ti vesti da donna ti facciamo sentir messa, perché come accusata per eresia non hai il
diritto di sentir messa. Giovanna dice ma io non voglio vestirmi da donna, però certo
che sentir messa. Però, patti chiari, non è che mi devo vestire da donna e restare per
sempre vestita da donna? Dicono ma sì, l'idea sarebbe quella. Ah no, allora no. Però se
mi fate fare un vestito da donna prometto che se mi mandate a messa me lo metto. Per
l'occasione i giudici accettano. Le mandano il sarto in cella a prendere le misure per
vestirla da donna. Il sarto per i gusti di Giovanna la tocca un po' troppo per prendere
le misure. Il risultato? Giovanna gli molla un ceffone, il sarto sparisce e non se ne parla
più del vestito da donna. Il processo va avanti. Non posso fare tanti esempi, ma è importante
sottolineare questa cosa. Tanti testimoni ci diranno che era pazzesco come questa ragazzina
teneva testa i suoi giudici. Ne sapeva più di loro. Sapeva sfuggire alle trappole. Molti
dicono che è chiaro che i giudici volevano incastrarla. Le facevano le domande apposta per vedere
se lei diceva l'eresia e lei se la cavava sempre. Un esempio, tanto per capire la mentalità
contorta di questa gente con cui ci confrontiamo. Le dicono, senti un po', sei in stato di grazia?
È una fregatura perché se dici sì sono in stato di grazia, come fai a saperlo? Vanna
Gloria è il diavolo che te lo fa credere. Sei in stato di grazia? Giovanna risponde. È
difficile rispondere a una domanda così. Dirò questo. Se sono in stato di grazia,
spero che Dio mi ci mantenga. Se non lo sono, spero che Dio mi ci metta.
Voi sorridete. In un pubblico di teologi dell'epoca che sono nati e cresciuti con queste
cose, sono tutti stupefatti. Come diavolo fa la ragazzina a saper rispondere così e evitare
la trappola in cui i teologi consumati hanno cercato di farla cadere. Più di una volta
quando le leggono i verbali, lei dice ma non ho mica detto quello. E c'è almeno un'occasione
in cui viene verbalizzato che lei a lettura dei verbali dice non ho detto quello. Pubblico,
cosa ho detto? E il pubblico dice hai ragione, non hai detto quello che hai scritto lì. E
li costringe a cambiare il verbale. Dopodiché va tutto molto bene. Vogliono fare le cose per
bene e formalmente corrette, ma la vogliono condannare. Perché il governo inglese ha già
fatto capire chiaramente che i giudici non usciranno di lì se non l'avranno condannata.
Finalmente arrivano a formulare i capi d'accusa. Giovanna è fortemente sospetta di essere una
strega, un falso profeta, di aver evocato gli spiriti maligni, e queste visioni da dove
vengono? Irrispettosa della Chiesa, provocatrice di guerra, assetata di sangue, indecente al
punto di abbandonare la modestia del suo sesso per vestirsi e armarsi come un uomo, contro la
legge divina e naturale e contro gli insegnamenti della Chiesa. Ed è fortemente sospetta di
eresia. A questo punto cosa succede? Mi devo richiamare, sto finendo, e sia chiaro, è tardissimo,
mi devo richiamare alla procedura di un processo per inquisizione. Lo scopo del processo,
formalmente, è che lei dica avete ragione, ho sbagliato, mi pento, mi sottometto. Questo
è lo scopo di ogni processo. I giudici hanno il fiato degli inglesi sul collo. Gli inglesi
gli hanno già detto, guarda che se la lasciate andare ce la riprendiamo noi e le vostre carriere
sono finite e avrete tutti moltissimi guai se la lasciate andare. Però i giudici stanno
facendo un processo in cui il loro scopo è di convincerla a abiurare, come si dice. E
dunque le presentano un'alternativa chiara. Deve sottomettersi alla Chiesa, deve ammettere
di aver avuto torto. Deve ammettere che le sue visioni erano false. Deve ammettere
che vestendosi da uomo ha disprezzato gli insegnamenti della Chiesa.
A questo punto, per la prima volta nella storia di questo lungo processo, si parla di una
cosa che magari non vi è venuta in mente, ma magari sì, e che di solito quando si parla
di processi di inquisizione viene in mente a tutti. La tortura. Non l'hanno mai torturata
finora, Giovanna. Ne parlano in questo momento, quando si tratta di dirle guarda che devi firmare
questa abiura, altrimenti finisci male. Guarda che devi ammettere, che devi confessare di aver
sbagliato. Secondo la procedura la portano nella stanza della tortura e le fanno vedere
gli strumenti di tortura. La procedura lo richiede ufficialmente, glieli fai vedere e poi la lasci
una notte a pensarci su per vedere cosa decide. Giovanna tiene duro, non vuole firmare. A questo
punto si riunisce una commissione ristretta, quanti sono? Sei, dodici, quindici? Quindici
dei giudici, frateologi, professori della Sorbona, per decidere è il caso di andare oltre
e torturarla o no? Su quindici, solo tre dicono che secondo loro sarebbe il caso di torturarla.
Gli altri, per un motivo o per l'altro, dicono che non è il caso. Notate che la cosa non è
così semplice, perché se voi avete presente la situazione, i veri nemici di Giovanna, gli
inglesi, cosa vogliono? Vogliono che lei accetti di firmare che abbiuri? No! Quindi c'è
anche il caso che quelli che volevano torturarla fossero quelli che speravano che questa deficiente
si salvasse, ammettendo di aver sbagliato. Parlo interpretando i loro pensieri, si capisce?
E c'è anche il caso che quelli che hanno detto no, no, non torturiamola, sono quelli
che hanno una gran fretta di poterla mandare al rogo come colpevole impenitente. Va a sapere,
noi non possiamo più entrare nelle loro anime adesso, sono morti tutti da un sacco di tempo.
Comunque fatto sta che non la torturano. Continuano a insistere, firma questa biura,
e qui guarda, è già tutto scritto. Lei non firma. La portano sulla piazza dove c'è
già un rogo pronto. E su questa piazza con il rogo pronto le fanno ascoltare il sermone
di un teologo che denuncia tutti i suoi errori. E le rileggono questa pergamena dove è già
scritto tutto. Lei confessa che si è sbagliata, che le sue visioni venivano dal diavolo,
non da Dio, che lei era un falso profeta e soprattutto che d'ora in poi non vestirà
mai più abiti maschili. Che è la cosa su cui insistono più che su tutte e noi siamo
liberi di pensare se è perché sono maschi paranoici o è perché sono teologi sottili
e hanno capito che quella è la cosa con cui la fregheranno. Le fanno leggere questa cosa.
Giovanna dice no, no, no. Dice guarda che il rogo è pronto. C'è la folla, c'è il
cordone di soldati inglesi, ci sono le autorità inglesi sul palco, tutti che aspettano di
vedere che lei rifiuta di firmare per accendere il rogo. A un certo punto Giovanna dice vabbè
d'accordo, firmo. Chi se ne frega, firmo. Datemi la penna, firmo. Nel momento in cui
prende la penna gli inglesi cominciano a rumoreggiare. I soldati inglesi cominciano a protestare,
a dire è una farsa, non è vero, ci prende tutti in giro, è una vergogna. Le autorità
inglesi se ne vanno dal palco protestando furibonde, minacciando i giudici di fargliela
vedere che non sono riusciti a incastrarla. Giovanna firma.
C'è un testimone, uno dei tre medici che hanno assistito Giovanna durante il processo,
perché ci sono tre medici che la assistono per poter certificare che nessuno l'ha toccata,
che non le han torto un capello e che tutto quello che lei ha detto l'ha detto di sua spontanea
volontà. Uno di questi medici più tardi dirà lei ha firmato perché le hanno promesso che
la liberavano se firmava. Va a sapere, è una testimonianza, noi non sappiamo se ci si
può credere o no. Fatto sta che lei firma. Ha firmato e a questo punto le leggono la sua
condanna. Siccome ha firmato non può essere messa a morte, quindi avrà la vita salva.
Ma sono talmente gravi le sue colpe che sarà tenuta in carcere a vita. È il 24 maggio
1431. Stavolta le danno gli abiti da donna e lei se li mette e va in carcere. E poi succede
qualcosa su cui chiudo rapidissimamente, ma su cui nessuno sa la verità. Giovanna è vestita
da donna in carcere. Qualcuno poi dirà, vestita da donna, era dura stare in carcere,
i carcerieri, è venuto uno, l'ha minacciata di violentarla. Insomma, com'è come non è,
in cella Giovanna trova degli abiti maschili. O forse li chiede, non lo sappiamo. Comunque
fatto sta che due giorni dopo, in carcere, è di nuovo vestita da uomo. Dopo avere firmato la
biura in cui riconosceva che vestirsi da uomo voleva dire offendere la chiesa e che
lei non l'avrebbe mai più fatto. Due giorni dopo è di nuovo vestita da uomo. Le autorità
inglesi, appena lo sanno, si fregano le mani. La teniamo. Giovanna è finita, Giovanna è
in trappola. È successo il 24 la condanna, il 26 la ritrovano vestita da uomo, il 29 il
tribunale si riunisce di nuovo e la condanna a morte come ricaduta nella sua colpa. Il 30
la portano al rogo. Riceve la confessione, la comunione. Altra stranezza procedurale totale
perché l'eretico ricaduto, che quindi ha insultato la chiesa, non dovrebbe ricevere la
confessione e la comunione. A lei invece la danno. La portano al rogo. Molti dei giudici
si sentono male e si dicono stiamo facendo l'errore della nostra vita, ci stiamo perdendo.
La folla piange. Giovanna sale al rogo. È un rogo enorme, molto più alto del solito, una
grande pira. La accendono. Giovanna muore quasi subito soffocata perché con una grande pira
il calore e la mancanza di ossigeno che si sviluppano la fanno fuori immediatamente. Spengono
il rogo, la fanno vedere bene che è morta, fanno vedere bene che è una donna perché
qualcuno dubitava anche di quello, poi riaccendono il rogo e la bruciano e disperdono le ceneri.
Qualche giorno dopo il boia che ha gestito tutta l'operazione si confessa col suo confessore
un frate domenicano e gli dice io lo so che mi son dannato facendo questa esecuzione.
E qui sarebbe bellissimo se io potessi dirvi che in quello stesso anno 1431 nasceva da qualche
parte una ragazza di cui vale la pena di parlare e che domani sera ve la racconterò.
E invece non è così. Per quest'anno è finita. Grazie. All'anno prossimo.
Grazie.